One of my favorite things is when conspiracy
theories conflict and you put the conspiracy
theorists together to argue over which of
their conspiracies is correct, and of course,
none of them are correct. And if you want to
see this happen, there's really no shortage of
options. You can put to flat theories together
to talk about how they can prove the earth is
flat. They will often have explanations that
conflict with each other. They can't both be true.
You put Antibalas together, one will tell you owe
the covid vaccine can't be trusted because it was
developed too quickly. New technology not tested.
Another will tell you it can't be trusted because
it's part of a long term mind control project
to control the population through vaccines.
It's been in planning for decades. They've been
waiting for a pandemic to justify its use. Wait,
wait a second. Hold on. Is the
problem that it's a long planned
population control device or that they just came
up with this in a few months and put it out there?
They can't. There are conflicting explanations.
It's just entertaining to see. I have a great
example for you today, which I love. During our
vacation early in the week, my Pillow CEO Mike
Lyndell told Steve Bannon on his war room show
that Donald Trump is going to be back in office
now. It's in August because of some new lawsuit.
Who the hell knows? But then in the middle of the
same week, a televangelist named Nathan French
says God told him Trump is coming back in April.
So which is it? A perfect show would be Mike
Lyndell and Nathan French arguing. Is Trump
going back to being president in April or is
Trump going back in August? And of course,
he's not coming back in either. Joe Biden is
president. So check this out. We'll start with
Michael Lyndell explaining the August hypothesis.
What I'm talking about, Steve, is what I have been
doing since January 9th. All the evidence I have,
everything is going to go before the Supreme Court
and the election of twenty twenty is going
bye bye. It was an attack by another country,
communism coming in. I don't know what they're
going to do with what after they pull it down. But
hang on. Hang on a second job.
Trump, go back in office in August.
So none of that is true. Nothing that Mike Lyndell
is doing is going to be going to go before the
Supreme Court. The twenty twenty election is
not going to be going bye bye. Communism didn't
come in and Trump will not be back in August.
But here is Nathan French. Totally different.
Trump will be back in April. Trump will be back
this month. Here's Nathan Frenches explanation.
Man, I said he was going to win big and he didn't
win. And the Lord says, yes, he did. And so you
have to recognize that he actually won with a
landslide victory. And a lot of people don't get
that. They tried to steal the election and it's
not going to work. God's about to lay it bare.
And that's not saying, look,
you know, he won big. I know he won big. So be
satisfied with that. Put on a good attitude and
let's move forward. I told you he's going
to win big. He did great. Now get over it.
He's not saying, oh, no, no, it's not over.
He's about to lay it bare. January, February,
March. I think we're going to find out in April.
I think everything's going to change. I see is I
mean, I feel like the people are waiting to see
when is the god of justice going to step in.
You're already seeing some of the things you
know on the news. And I don't want to get into
too much of that because there are certain things
I can't really say. There's a lot of stuff I know.
So this guy says it's actually April when all
will be laid to bear to use his vocabulary. So, of
course, they're both wrong. And after August comes
and goes, it would be just as interesting to put
them both in a room together to explain why were
you wrong about April and why were you wrong about
August? And I'm sure they would disagree about
why it hasn't happened as well. Now, one of the
things that is interesting here is comparing and
contrasting the sort of psyche of these two guys.
Are they merely con men using different
techniques to con their audiences? Are they
mentally ill in the sense that they're delusional
in a diagnostic sense? Do they really believe they
are talking to God in the sense that this is
mostly a religious thing? I actually can't tell
Nathan. French seems more like a guy who literally
believes the religious stuff that leads him to
thinking he is speaking to God. Some would say
that is a delusion. Mike Lyndell strikes me more
like as a half con man, but also not connected
to reality in what may be a. Diagnostic situation
or maybe related to, you know, some people have
talked about substance abuse or something else,
it's really difficult to tell where this is on
the what is the scale even con to full delusional
and maybe in the middle of someone who saying, I
don't know if I believe this, but I kind of feel
OK bringing it to people because it's making
money. I don't know. I don't know. But let me
know what you think the parameters are. What is
the scale on which we analyze these people and
where on the scale do you think Nathan French and
Mike Lyndell fall? They're both wrong factually,
but there are underlying motivations are
certainly an interesting thing to think about